der klimawandel ist da und er wird uns
wohl mit noch voller breitseite
erwischen aber bereits heutzutage hat
der katastrophale auswirkung und zwar
nicht nur für natur und tiere sondern
vor allem auch für uns menschen weltweit
aber auch in deutschland und das
schlimme ist der klimawandel ist durch
uns verursacht worden
ja ihr habt euch das thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt die
krassesten folgen die es heute schon zu
sehen gibt also herzlich willkommen bei
klicks um science-fiction
krankheiten breiten sich aus durch den
klimawandel werden sich krankheiten
ausbreiten wenn logisch
krankheitsüberträger wie etwa anopheles
stechmücke aber auch nagetiere und
zugvögel die krankheiten übertragen
mögen es eher warm und feucht durch eine
erhöhte temperatur verbessern sich also
ihre lebensbedingungen und diese erhöhte
temperatur
die gibt es jetzt schon aber das ist nur
eine folge des klimawandels auch die
allergiker unter uns also etwa 20 bis 30
prozent der deutschen werden zunehmend
leiden denn durch den menschengemachten
klimawandel kommt es wohl dazu dass
pflanzen früher austreiben und blühen
pflanzen die allergenes potenzial haben
werden sich zudem weiter ausbreiten und
als wäre das nicht genug wird wohl auch
noch das trinkwasser knapp schon jetzt
sorgen kaymer in warmen und ärmeren
regionen der erde zu krankheiten wie
cholera im schlimmsten fall sogar zu
epidemien und es sterben jedes jahr vier
millionen menschen weil sauberes
trinkwasser nicht in ausreichender menge
verfügbar ist durch den erwarteten
temperaturanstieg den der klimawandel
mit sich bringen wird wird das problem
zukünftig noch größer durch den anstieg
des meeresspiegels könnte zudem auch das
grundwasser versalzen werden und durch
die mögliche überflutung von
mülldeponien wird sauberes wasser noch
knapper die luftverschmutzung steigt
enorm studien erwarten in den nächsten
jahren extreme hitzewellen als folge des
klimawandels mit der starken
sonneneinstrahlung und den hohen
temperaturen bildet sich aus sogenannten
vorläufersubstanzen bodennahes ozon
unterschieden wird zwischen dem
harmlosen stratosphärischen ozon das uns
ja sogar vor schädlichen uv-strahlen
schützt und dem troposphäre ozon das ist
ein luftschadstoff der in der
menschlichen lunge zu krassen scheffelt
und das ist echt nicht ohne europäische
studien ergaben einen zusammenhang
zwischen der täglichen sterberate und
der höhe der ozonkonzentration die
sterberate stieg um 0,3 prozent pro zehn
mikrogramm je kubikmeter also zehn
millionstel gramm pro kubikmeter anstieg
das wetter wird immer extremer
die letzten jahre waren hinsichtlich der
weltweiten temperaturen rekordverdächtig
nicht nur 2014 2015 und 2016 sondern vor
allem auch 2007
zehn waren außergewöhnlich laut der
weltwetterorganisation wmo haben hat die
temperatur 1,1 grad über dem
vorindustriellen wert gelegen mit dabei
außerdem temperaturen von mehr als 50
grad celsius in asien rekordhöhe cans in
der karibik und im atlantik sowie eine
sehr lange dürre in afrika und ja lange
zeit haben sich geber forschungsteams
schwergetan solche extreme
wetterphänomene in einen direkten
zusammenhang mit dem klimawandel zu
bringen doch mittlerweile machen
schnelle computer und optimierte
klimamodelle das möglich und tatsächlich
fiel der eben aufgezählten
wetterereignisse lassen sich mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit auf den klimawandel
zurück führen in einer großen studie
haben 33 forschungsteams aus der ganzen
welt wetterphänomene im jahr 2014
analysiert die entscheidende frage waren
die extremen wetterereignisse von 2014
auf natürliche schwankungen im
klimasystem zurückzuführen oder waren
sie tatsächlich folgen des
menschengemachten klimawandels thomas
kahl einer der beteiligten forscher mit
dem fazit wir können demonstrieren dass
einzelne ereignisse sowie temperatur
extreme oft mit den von uns zusätzlich
in die atmosphäre gepumpten
treibhausgasen verknüpft sind andere
extreme darunter regenfälle sind weniger
eindeutig auf den klimawandel und
menschliche einflüsse zurückzuführen
der klimawandel hat also durchaus
einfluss auf die häufigkeit und
spannbreite von solchen
extremereignissen im jahr 2014
beispielsweise macht man ihn
verantwortlich für die hitzerekorde in
europa china argentinien und korea und
auch für die lange dürre in ostafrika
die starken regenfälle im winter 2013/14
in großbritannien und die winterstürme
seien dagegen nicht eindeutig auf den
klimawandel zurückzuführen und in
zukunft wird das wetter immer nur noch
extremer werden dazu heiko paeth von der
universität würzburg wenn man in der
bodennahen atmosphäre mehr energie hat
weil die treibhausgaskonzentrationen
gestiegen sind und einen höheren wärme
gehalt in den unteren
atmosphärenschichten bedingen dann
sollte man alleine vom standpunkt der
physikalischen plausibilität davon
ausgehen dass es in zukunft mehr extreme
ereignisse gibt der meeresspiegel steigt
und nimmt uns unser zuhause erst vor
kurzem hat die nasa ein
echte katastrophenmeldung herausgegeben
neue kartierungen zeigen dass deutlich
mehr gletscher grönlands von einer
schmelze bedroht sind als bisher
angenommen nämlich zwei bis viermal so
viele gletscher wie bislang angenommen
und das hat fatale folgen der
meeresspiegel wird stärker und schneller
ansteigen als bisher vorhergesagt nasa
vertreter george will es sagt diese
ergebnisse zeigen dass das eis in
grönland stärker vom klimawandel bedroht
ist als wir erwartet hatten
selbst eine geringe globale erwärmung
hat wohl dramatische konsequenzen für
das eis in grönland berechnung zufolge
ist es schon heute so dass die
eisschmelze in grönland stärker zum
anstieg des meeresspiegels beiträgt als
die schmelze der antarktis eine
komplette gletscherschmelze grönlands
hätte weitreichende folgen nach den
neuen berechnungen würde der
meeresspiegel dann um 7,4 zwei meter
ansteigen und auch wenn grönland sehr
weit von uns entfernt ist werden vor
allem wir in deutschland aber auch die
niederlande und belgien sehr stark
betroffen seien genauso wie menschen in
vielen anderen ländern dieser welt
indonesien ägypten bangladesch oder
thailand
wenn der meeresspiegel nur um einen
halben bis ganzen meter steigt würde der
lebensraum zahlreicher menschen komplett
unter wasser stehen es gibt berechnungen
nachdem bereits im jahr 2050 der prozess
des abschmelzens unwiderruflich in gang
gesetzt worden sein wird wenn sowohl das
grönländische inlandeis und auch die
antarktis eiskappe komplett schmelzen
würden würde der meeresspiegel um 70
meter ansteigen eine absolut unfassbare
vorstellung auch hier berlin wäre unter
wasser
und schon jetzt passiert in teilen der
welt der reinste horror durch den
anstieg des meeresspiegels sind im
pazifik mindestens acht ganze inseln
verschwunden für immer betroffen sind
inseln der salomonen einem inselstaat in
der südsee und auch mikronesien ein
inselstaat im westlichen pazifischen
ozean in beiden regionen liegt der
anstieg des meeresspiegels weit über dem
durchschnitt dort wurde nämlich sogar
ein jährlicher anstieg von 1,2
zentimetern gemessen abgesehen davon
dass ihre heimat inseln eine große
historische bedeutung für ihre bewohner
haben sind die menschen dort die 2
alles aufzugeben sie müssen also
entweder in höhere regionen umsiedeln
oder aber ihr leben an einem anderen ort
komplett neu anfangen eine wirklich
traurige entwicklung die menschen stehen
vor existenzbedrohenden fragen wie was
passiert mit uns und unserer heimat wo
können wir hin
wie können wir überleben was passiert
mit unserer kultur werden wir jetzt teil
eines anderen staates und werden wir
dort akzeptiert so wie wir sind und die
zukunft für die insel im pazifischen
ozean sieht nicht gut aus sechs weitere
inseln dieser insel ketten sind
ebenfalls kurz davor vom meer
verschluckt zu werden so die traurige
bilanz des forschungsteams glück im
unglück dass diese zumindest ungewohnt
sind und kein menschenleben direkter
gefahr ausgesetzt ist aber auch andere
kleine inselstaaten wie die
marshallinseln und die bewohner der
malediven beispielsweise denen droht
dieses katastrophenszenario und die
erosion der küsten ist nur ein problem
von vielen dass mehr wasser vergiftet ja
auch das ackerland und nimmt den
menschen ihre nahrungsgrundlage an den
betroffenen orten wachsen oft nicht mal
mehr kokospalmen nicht umsonst gibt es
die so genannte allianz kleiner
inselstaaten ein zusammenschluss von
rund 40 inseln und küsten nationen die
in ihrer existenz bedroht sind auch orte
an denen wir gerne urlaub machen sind
dabei zum beispiel die dominikanische
republik kuba die seychellen oder die
fidschi-inseln es gibt studien die
prognostizieren dass im jahr 2100 ein
fünftel der weltbevölkerung
klimaflüchtlinge sind das sind 1,5
milliarden überflutete küstenregionen
sorgen diesem szenario nach für eine
massenflucht ins landesinnere wo dann
nutzbare flächen viel zu knapp werden
nahrungsmittel würden knapp
durch den klimawandel werden sich
temperatur und niederschlag in vielen
regionen der erde verändern und damit
auch das wachstum der meisten
kulturpflanzen ernteverluste wird es
wohl vor allem in den niederen breiten
geben zudem werden wohl auch
pflanzenkrankheiten die landwirtschaft
shading betroffen sind dann mal wieder
die eh schon armen länder der welt die
schon jetzt gegen unterernährung und
überbevölkerung kämpfen und wie gerade
erwähnt worden durch die geflüchteten
aus den überschwemmten gebieten wird der
platz knapp mehr als erstes neues zum
thema klimawandel und zu allen anderen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video und zur begrüßung
gibt es auch ein kleines goodie einfach
hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das aber mit der glocke vergessen und
hier geht es weiter damit dafür auch
draufklicken klimawandel bestätigt
skeptiker endgültig widerlegt ansonsten
bis dann bleib dran